8皆さんはじめせそうですもう新年度ですよ
新しい学校とか行く人
会社とか就職する人も
まあ不安でしょうけど
頑張りましょう
ね今日はそんな皆さんにオススメの漫画を
紹介します甘いないし地獄大甲子園です
ジャンプ
ただしっていう人はいると思いますけどじゃんってなぁ
あの
これじゃんただ化している
漫画なんですけどもうちょっと多分野球好きや夜景好きな人は
おざぶマークしてるんでしょうねこれ
本当に夜景の常識を覆すような漫画ねー
なんかすごい200キロの球投げる選手とか
お題はなんか試合中に選手がみんな死んじゃったりするんですよ
相手が張ったねー連れがピッチャーなんですよ
なんか自分の選手がもうみんな怪我しちゃって2人しかいなくて
ピッチャーとキャッチャーしかいないんですよまぁでも
打たれたら終わりなんで
どういう作戦にで8日って言ったら
ピッチャーなんか野球てる滑り止めのパパなんかこのあるじゃないですか
あれをめっちゃ子
手に塗って
なんか時間稼ぎして仲間を来るのを待とうという作戦なんですけど
じゃあもその球の中に何か時限爆弾魔仕込んであって
エコー
ずっと味方ンって言っちゃ振るわけじゃないですか
そしたらもうなんかアイゼン選手のバッターがディアにやしててなんか
クック3タイプ塗っててキャッチャーがキャッチャーのもう選手がいなくてそう
酵素の自分の味方な高層先生なんですけど
校長先生が気づくんですよこれは罠だってなって
早く投げるだけローって言って
あのピッチャーは慌てて投げるんですけど遅くて
ボールが次元化けなんで中に
なんか大量の空気が入ってて釘
って爆発してちゃすーって体中
釘だけに入っ
だったりするんですよ
イワンキーでもわからないでしょ book お店に売ってると思うんだよ
すごいね200キロ足らなけれ選手とかね第2に皆顔れちゃうんですよ
いい
ああああああ
本当に甲子園甲子園好きな人にはたまらない
いっぺんになってると思うんだよ
城福汚染3的に見えてください
ございました
じゃあ